j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle mes parents
ils vont passer mais quand maintenant
d'accord gagner un peu de temps bonjour
je viens ici à jamais la vie est ce
qu'on vous semble oui mais pas de sexe
oral
je comptais pas parler de sexe oral très
bien et vite il sujet reviendra sur le
tapis comment on repasse comptes aura
plus de visites ou bien intimant photo
dc c'est vrai mais pas question de sexe
oral vous avez ma parole du mouvement
fils chéri attentes ou à un truc étrange
et les hommes de la famille peuvent
voyager dans le temps moi c'est une
réaction tiendront une autre je crois
avoir opté pour merde d'accepter les
années soixante dix
tu te mets quelque part dans le noir tu
penses au moment où tu veux aller trop
loin
ciman fait et vit ici avec toi mais je
m'occupe la chambre d'amis on n'a pas de
chambre d'amis mais je partage sa
chambre en ami autrement dit pas de sexe
entre nous d'aucune nature
je vous demande pardon excusez moi ça va
compliquer mon année ça va te compliquer
la vie
bien que ce soit moins spectaculaire que
ça n'en a l'air on peut pas tuer hitler
saute hélène de troie